[Music]
recognizing images in other apps with
seeing AI so far we've seen the
different channels which allow you to
get different types of information about
the world around you
however sometimes you want to get that
kind of information about photos which
already exist maybe in your camera roll
but also within other apps like Twitter
or whatsapp or mail with seeing AI you
can actually use the same technology to
recognize those photos too whenever you
come across an image which you want a
description of you use the apps share
feature not because you want to share it
but because at the bottom of that share
pain there are different actions like
copy and print and there's also an
action called recognized with seeing AI
so when you select that you will get the
same descriptions that you've seen with
other channels on that photo that came
from Twitter or whatsapp now that's
really cool because sometimes you'll get
an invitation in an email which is just
an image instead of the actual text or
maybe you are on Twitter and there's a
funny photo that everyone's commenting
on so now with this feature you can
participate in those two so here I have
the Twitter app with a tweet from my
colleague here open let's see what it
says so many chores to do today
landscape image double tap two beautiful
size image so clearly that's a comment
about this image but wouldn't it be
great if I could know what was in that
image that's what we can do with seeing
AI so let's open up the image landscape
image double tap and hold for more
actions and let's bring up those actions
enable airdrop sharing button and across
the bottom here we have different
actions to perform on the image cancel
tweet photo button drag save photo
button drop open in the far
button to recognize with zai but that's
the one we want processing text got a
drop off my laundry and pick up my bone
seen a dog sitting on the seat of a car
huh hubby Microsoft logo appears